hey 42 here this bouncy man is rich
uncle Pennybags what you knew that
didn't know too many simply asked you
not Alima he's known for his waistcoat
jacket top hat mustache and of course
his monocle for wait a minute the
monopoly man has never had a monocle I
know you're absolutely certain that he
does but I promise you mr. penny bug has
never ever had a monocle you have made
it up entirely this image doesn't exist
don't panic you're not alone the vast
majority of people are absolutely
certain that they remember them not a
man with a monocle so what's going on it
well these people and possibly yourself
have all fallen victim to the Mandela
effect the Mandela effect is when a
great number of people remember
something in a completely different way
to how it actually was or remember an
event that never actually happens you
know those times when your mind betrays
you are certain it happens that way but
the facts say otherwise it happens to us
all and psychiatrists have a word for it
confabulation a confabulation is a
disturbance or distortion of a memory
well some people say there's more to the
Mandela effects than a simple distortion
of memories and the real reason that
millions of people's memories are
betraying them is far more terrifying
and sinister the name Mandela effect is
named after the man himself ex-president
of South Africa Nelson Mandela in 1962
Mandela was arrested and thrown in jail
for 27 years for starting the workers
strike at a time when South Africa who
is led by a minority white rule with an
iron fist black and whites were
segregated
this was the apartheid a large number of
people around the world vividly remember
seeing footage broadcast on television
of Nelson Mandela dying in
Prison during the 80s they even remember
seeing his funeral live on international
TV of course this isn't true Mandela was
released from prison became president
and died in 2013 at home so what's going
on here
how come millions recall seeing his
death in the 80s well it's the first big
mystery that coined the term Mandela
effect people are constantly discovering
new examples of the Mandela effect in
recent years many have come into the
public eye by the Internet one of the
most spine-tingling is the mystery of
the Berenstein bears the American
viewers the Mongols will remember a
series of children's books from the 60s
onwards this lovable family of birds was
a significant part of everybody's
childhood in the u.s. there were over
300 books in total and not to mention a
TV series in 2003 that went by the same
name that variants the birth but here's
the truly shocking thing the Berenstein
bears never existed sure there was a
cute family of bears but they were
actually called the berenstain bears
with an A this has seriously messed with
the heads of millions of Americans
because quite literally everyone knew it
as the Berenstein bears many have set it
down through the creator's changing the
name at some point because Berenstain
sounds less Jewish than Bernstein but
the name was never changed it was named
after the two creators Stan and Jan
Berenstain but something eerie is
definitely going on here there are some
very rare examples of official
merchandise being uncovered deep from
the back people's garages and attics
showing the franchise being spelt Baron
V such as on this old VHS but to confuse
matters even further the name on the
front of the tape
it's belt Berenstain creepy but could
this just be no more than a typo by the
graphic designer
you remember the most famous line from
Star Wars Sochi Luke I am your father
except that line was never set in the
film what Darth Vader actually said was
no I am your father a small difference
sure but then why does the whole world
keep saying Luke I am your father
there's more remember Silence of the
Lambs
everyone knows what Hannibal said to
Clarice when they first met I mean it's
only the most famous quote from the
entire film he said hello Clarice nope
never said it that line never appeared
in the film don't believe me go and
watch it Hannibal
actually said a rather forgettable good
morning
even the University of Richmond quoted
the fictitious line in a scientific
paper even people who have never seen
Silence of the Lambs are familiar with
Hannibal Lecter sinister hello Clarice
another stark example length of the
Mandela effect
remember Sex in the City it was actually
called
Sex and the City the KitKat logo doesn't
have a dash in it it never has the Queen
Snow White never said mirror mirror on
the wall oh and remember Jessie the
well-known American peanut butter
there's no such thing it's called jiff
not Jessie hell I'm British and even I
recall it being called jiffy
but then is that just because that's
what millions of other people have been
calling it all this time The Flintstones
was actually called The Flintstones
despite no one in the history of mankind
ever calling it that so is there an
explanation to all of this well kind of
there are three theories that do explain
the Mandela effect what all of them are
equally is terrifying the first popular
explanation involves parallel universes
some believe that we live our lives not
just within one universe but we are
instead slipping and sliding between
multiple universes within the multiverse
without ever realizing it each universe
is ever so slightly different and some
believe that the Mandela effect is
people noticing the minor differences
between these over dimensions or
universes or perhaps we don't travel
between universes what if we've always
been in the same universe but instead
memories are leaked from other universes
and seep into our universe as they
intertwine and collide this rather
outlandish theory isn't currently backed
up by any specific research but that
doesn't mean it isn't scientifically
possible new quantum mechanics theories
suggest that there are multiple
universes and they do interact with each
other possibly sharing information so
when we remember something vastly
different to what the archives tell us
if it's information coming from a
parallel universe
or is it something far more sinister as
we all know if something strange happens
there's a conspiracy theory surrounding
it it's the second law of the internet
after don't click on strange links
Mandela effect conspiracy enthusiasts
believe the infamous Illuminati or
whatever shady group of men in suits are
running the world behind the scenes have
actually changed subtle elements of
history to better suit their new world
order just hoping that we won't notice
but oops
some people have why in our militant
group of secret world leaders would
think that the monopoly man's molecule
wasn't quite fitting for their new world
order is anybody's guess but what is you
actually made all of this or and this is
the most terrifying of all the
explanations because this implies that
our memories are nowhere near as
reliable
which poor yes what I'm about to tell
you is by far the most scientifically
accepted explanation for the Mandela
effect psychologists say that we
remember these events books films and
images so vividly differently to how
they actually are because we've all
created false memories what do you
remember most about your childhood is it
what you ate for dinner each night or
what you watched on TV your memories of
these things are probably fuzzy at best
yet you can remember the names of all of
your friends and that time when you
broke someone's window playing football
you probably remember all the times you
were nursing and that's because you
talked about those events afterwards
with your friends your parents talked to
you about it afterwards you received
punishment in relation to that event
conversation is arguably the most
powerful memory creator there is and
talking about an event after it happens
creates far stronger memories done
whilst the event is actually taking
place memories are created by
connections forming in the brain your
brain is full of cells called neurons
and connections between them called
synaptic imagine a neuron that
represents a window and neurosis
represents the ball as a child the
moment you kick that ball through
batshit Bob's window a physical synaptic
connection was created in your brain
between these two neurons thus forming a
weak memory of the event what then when
you tell your mates about how you just
broke bash it Bob's window that
connection actually gets thicker
strengthening that memory then when your
mum confiscated your gameboy afterwards
the connection grows once again but it
goes even further every time you were
taught that memory from here on out the
connection gets stronger by simply
remembering something you are
strengthening that memory forever of
course this also means that if you
remember something
wrongly every time you remember what
actually happened you are instead
strengthening the incorrect memory
that's already there this is why we
can't see past our memory our brains
tell us that they are unquestionably
reliable but we have no way to know
whether that memory was false to begin
with until someone comes along than
tells us or shows us that we have
remembered it incorrectly this is called
false memory and it is by far the most
likely thing that's causing the Mandela
worsening in 1970 for psychologists
Loftus and Palmer showed 45 students a
clip of a real car crash then asked the
question how fast were the cars going
when they hit each other the range of
answers were vastly unreliable but it
was also discovered that by changing the
wording of the question also completely
change the people's answers those who
were asked how fast were the cars going
when they contacted each other gave a
much slower speed the knows who were
asked how fast were the cars going when
they smashed into each other
demonstrating just how unreliable
memories can be and how our
conversations with others can distort
our memories mandela didn't die in the
80s like many forms but in 1990 he was
released from prison the event was
significant and was broadcast on TV
across the world with millions tuning in
to watch there was a large state
procession on the streets in South
Africa to celebrate his release which
many Americans and others remember
watching but such an event could easily
be misconstrued to have been a funeral
procession Nelson Mandela's name was
nowhere near as famous back then as it
is now so people may not have paid much
attention to what was actually happening
at the time thus creating a false memory
such he died the Berenstein bears was
read by school kids who couldn't give a
toss about proper spelling Steen is also
a far more common suffix to a
name none sustained so it makes perfect
sense that children simply call this the
incorrect name of Berenstein bears when
discussing the book we're friends and so
grew up with this false memory the same
logic applies to movie quotes
you've probably heard Luke I am your
father and hello Clarice many many more
times in real life during conversations
with others and you have heard them in
the actual film at least the part in the
film where the line was supposed to be
it turns out that every instance of the
Mandela effect can be explained by
collective false memory which it's
disappointing to some unscary to others
the simple fact that everyone you speak
to shares the same misconceptions about
something actually strengthens that
false memory you've likely spread
misinformation to hundreds of others
when you've quoted lines and films that
were never said and discussed event very
differently than what actually happens
we are all part of the problem and new
examples of the Mandela effect will
continue to surface because nobody's
memory is perfect and I for one welcome
them because that's what makes us human
and such curiosities keeps life so
interesting thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video support me on patreon
before you forget who I am and tell your
friends you watch the guy on YouTube
called
36 click up there to become a patron
doing so helps me to make better videos
and click down now to watch another
video and if you haven't already don't
forget to subscribe